toujours en france plusieurs dizaines de
personnes se sont rassemblées devant le
tribunal de versailles en début d'après
midi
la raison la mise en examen de trois
pompiers en 2009 pour violences sur
mineur qui a été requalifiée en atteinte
sexuelle ce qui est un délit et non un
crime l'association nou tout ainsi que
les faits n'étaient présents cet après
midi pour soutenir les victimes
julie qui affirment avoir été violées
dans ces 13 à ses 15 ans le tribunal
examinait aujourd'hui sert caisse une
requalification des faits en violences
réunion le délibéré aura lieu du 11
novembre
on est là face à l'horreur la plus
absolue avec des pompiers qui est on le
sait savent parfaitement qu'elle a entre
13 et 15 ans savent parfaitement calé en
profonde détresse psychiatrique et
psychique savent parfaitement qu'elle a
un traitement de cheval qui abolit
complètement toute possibilité de
consentir et pourtant ils appliquent une
tradition ignoble des pompiers de paris
qu'on appelle la coche
c'est à dire on se refile le numéro une
jeune fille avec qui on enchaîne des
relations sexuelles voilà la vérité de
ce dossier voilà ce qui doit être dit
voilà ce qui doit être jugé voilà ce qui
doit être achevé j'espère que enfin le
dossier va être vu pour ce qu'il est et
non pas parce que ce sont des pompiers
parce que ce sont des militaires voient
la justice doit être rendue à julie
c'est impensable qu'ils aient reconnu à
minima un acte sexuel
alors qu'elles avaient moins de 15 ans
et qui est pas à minima atteintes
sexuelles de retenue pour ces jeunes
c'est impensable
elle a été violée donc il va falloir
assumer ce qui s'est passé c'est un
crime c'est devant les assises
voilà